[Music]
welcome to tonight's conversation i'm
very pleased to be here as yvette said
i'm the editor of quantum magazine
and um so happy that
steven strogatz is joining us tonight to
talk
all about
really about his career my goal here
tonight is to try to take you on a bit
of a journey behind the scenes of
steve's evolution as a mathematician and
teacher
through
book writing and public speaking and now
with the podcast that he is hosting
for quanta i want to start the
conversation by talking about
you as a teacher because i see you
beyond all of your wonderful research
and all the books and even all the books
and all the public speaking that you've
done i see a lot of that at its core
as a form of teaching first of all why
is teaching so important to you and
what is it that
you feel like um
i'll say that my
my own sense of what makes you such a
great teacher is a certain level of
empathy
okay because i think that's one thing
that separates great teachers and
teachers who maybe you know are trying
to communicate something but maybe less
successfully but i want to hear from you
um why do you care so much about
teaching and what is it that you try to
do that's maybe a little bit different
wow tom you're bowling me over with that
introduction and all those super kind
words thank you
yeah you've really put your finger on
things that i do care about
the word empathy i would like to single
out because um you very astutely i think
he really hit the nail on the head
that's
i think that's the single most important
thing in teaching and writing
um and communicating to try to
anticipate what's in the listener's mind
or in the reader's mind or the student's
mind if it's a class
so um
i don't know
it's a really interesting question guys
why do i care so much about teaching
that
i don't think anyone ever asked me that
before and i'm not sure i know what i
would say
my instinctive response is because i
have something
delightful and beautiful that i want to
show you how are you able to
strip away what you know because i think
one of the challenges for people who um
especially mathematicians who know a lot
about their subject who are very precise
i mean it's part of the training i think
as mathematicians that you're extremely
precise you want to be very rigorous in
the way that you do your mathematics so
everything that you say
you know there's 10 other statements
that you have to say to sort of you know
make that as precise as possible how are
you able to both self-edit and
put yourself in the shoes of someone who
doesn't know the things that you know
right there's certain there's a certain
curse of knowledge
hurdle here that you have to be able to
say okay this person you know doesn't
necessarily know all the things i know
how do you put yourself in their shoes
this feeling of bursting and wanting to
share something can also lead someone to
be extremely boring right it's almost
the definition of a boar someone who is
going on and on
but you don't care what they're talking
about
and
so that's a key part of good teaching or
good writing
um is what you first said empathy that i
have to but but the specific part of
empathy i'm talking about here is i have
to help you love the question
that's the classic mistake if if the
teacher or the writer goes on about look
at the great way that this problem was
solved or um so you might spend too much
time on the process or even on the
answer itself look at this amazing
theory or a result or theorem let me
show it to you
that is not going to work the the first
thing the student has to have is love
which is a bit of a strange thing to say
right you don't normally think that math
class is about love or or any other
class but in fact that's the teacher's
first job
is help the student fall in love with
the question or the topic or whatever it
is because once they love it
most of your work is done there's this
perception that math is this big scary
difficult thing and that there's a lot
of fear about it in society and i think
that
um you know a lot of places i've worked
as a journalist editors would sort of
assume that readers would be afraid of
math and so they would you know try to
write stories in a particular way
um
but
what you said about love i think gets at
the heart of
how to sort of overcome that fear right
if you can
make people
care and be interested in it not
necessarily giving them something big
and scary and difficult at first um
maybe you you have a better chance
um what are some of the tactics to help
someone fall in love with a question
humor is one sure if you can get the
person laughing if there's something
delightful because it's funny or
surprising
or
tantalizing
that's why puzzles work so well right if
if you give a little kid a puzzle that
is at the right level for them
you don't really have to teach them or
tell them anything they're i mean think
about this i i know i've given plenty of
lectures where in the course of the
lecture i'll ask
people to start thinking about a problem
if the problem is good they will stop
listening to the lecture they want to
start thinking about the problem
and um
that's because problems of the right
type are inherently engaging and
so
surprise humor those are those are good
tactics um
people are interested in people if you
have a story about a person that can
work i mean there are many devices and
all of your great science writers that
at quanta know these things they're all
parts of the hook
so that's why a good writer starts with
a hook
right and so i think as a teacher
it's the same thing
also i like that you
phrase uh
what i do as being a teacher because i
think of myself
if in one word as a teacher a lot of my
colleagues are driven by a desire to
solve
mysteries and that's a little bit of a
different desire
i mean yes you can teach yourself
something by solving
but um i'm very happy to explain someone
else's solution
in other words i i think it might be let
me say it this way i think in math and
in science generally we have in the
language of economics a distribution
problem
not a production problem i think we're
producing a lot of great math and
science
that is
not landing in its
on the target
because we spend so much effort on the
creation and the discovery and we're not
so necessarily trained or some of us
interested in dissemination i think of
my own grad students who say i've solved
the problem i can't stand writing it up
i just want to do the next problem and i
understand that for people who love to
solve puzzles that is the really fun
part
but the writing and the explaining
is part of the social enterprise of
science and and i think the work isn't
done until you do that part so uh
i love that you uh went through some of
the things that go into empathizing and
being able to communicate
in a way that um
helps people
enjoy
math and and learning and i i want to
give this a spin i want to uh do this
i'm sorry to put you on the spot but i i
want to give you a a
a uh something to
try out
on the crowd and so i i'd like to ask
you
this um i'd like to ask you to
um
break down
one of the most famous equations and
what is widely considered the most
beautiful equation in mathematics
euler's identity
you know for
imagine an audience of people who
maybe remember some of high school math
right
and so this is of course
e i pi plus one equals zero
if you could just use some of those
skills and techniques to may i be while
i'm stalling to think of how to do it
i may ask some questions of course of
course for instance does my
listener know
e should i spend time explaining e
or do they know i think that i think
that um it would be fair to to assume
that that a lot of people wouldn't know
a lot about e okay yes so there is a
certain equation
that is often considered
the most beautiful equation in all of
math
uh that as thomas said is the letter e
which
i'll tell you what each letter means e
to the i pi power plus one equals zero
so let's first talk about each of the
letters
so e
e for exponential
having to do with things that grow
exponentially or decay exponentially so
we're seeing that unfortunately right
now with the pandemic we've gotten a a
very brutal dose of what exponential
growth means when something builds on
itself
and multiplies by a constant
factor week after week or day after day
so exponential growth
we see all over the place in the
universe in our own bodies in the case
of viruses proliferating unfortunately
we also have exponential decay when
things decay by a constant factor day
after day so there's so e is kind of
more broadly a mascot of calculus
e is about this kind of continuous
change where the thing that's changing
keeps changing at a changing rate so it
grows but grows faster and the higher it
gets the faster it grows or okay so e is
to me a kind of personification of a
whole branch of math having to do with
growth and decay
next i so e to the i
i for imaginary the imaginary number
that enlarged our concept of what
numbers could be
this this was we think of numbers as
little children as magnitudes things
that you can mark off on a number line
or that have to do with counting cookies
or whatever but numbers in more advanced
parts of algebra are things that are
kind of number like they obey some of
the rules that we learned about ordinary
numbers
but they're more powerful than that
and
they were so mysterious when they were
first discovered they were called
imaginary because they didn't act like
the usual quantities that we thought
about
but but i turns out to be crucial in
algebra and so speaking with this
language of personification
i is part
is sort of our mascot of algebra
pi everyone knows because it's the most
famous greek letter that's a number
that stands in for geometry but not just
geometry of circles
remember pi is the ratio of the
circumference of a circle to the
diameter but so pi is something about
converting straight things like
diameters into round things like circles
and there's a very profound mystery
about converting the straight to the
round which is that infinity somehow
comes into it you you all know that if
you write down the digits of pi
you get
3.14159 this goes on forever they never
repeat they don't show any pattern so
somehow in making this conversion from
the straight to the round infinity comes
into play and infinity is left out of
the equation but it's sort of lurking
there in pi
and um
everybody's interested in infinity so
now we've got
calculus growth and decay we've got
algebra we've got geometry but then we
have the most basic parts of arithmetic
plus
equals 1 zero and i don't have to tell
you what one and zero are but they're
like the beginnings of math right one
the beginning of counting zero the void
so it's all packed into this one
equation and on top of all of that it's
unbelievably surprising what does it
mean to raise a number to an imaginary
power
and and somehow the formula is actually
true e to the i pi plus one equals zero
it has everything in the shortest space
so it's it's parsimonious it's beautiful
it's surprising it connects i mean in
math the aesthetic high point is when
you draw connections between things that
don't seem connected so here we connect
algebra geometry calculus arithmetic
i mean that's a pretty beautiful
equation absolutely thank you so much
wow
oh okay that's like a performance yeah
sorry for putting on the spot there and
for the record this was not rehearsed no
it's not real very much just threw that
uh out there for steve because i knew he
would um
nail it and you did thank you so much
thank you so much um
so
i want to now kind of walk back a little
bit in in time and i know that you know
a little bit about your childhood but we
haven't talked a lot about it i know
that you know you've played tennis and
basketball and you're really into chess
you're you know a really good chess
player but you weren't particularly
outdoorsy
um didn't like bugs yeah um
but
but uh so i just want
can you tell us you know how when did
math enter the equation when did you
know
that both that you were you know really
good at it and that you wanted to pursue
it
interesting you assume i'm good at it
all my lowest grades in college were in
math really yeah i don't think i'm
especially good at it i i not saying
that for false modesty i'm not an
inherently modest person i i
i'm really good at certain things but
math is probably one of my weakest
subjects um in terms of
pure brain power like to follow a
complicated argument all my colleagues
are better if i if you ranked me in the
math department i would probably be last
i'm sure of it i i'm slow
uh anything that requires doing a fast
calculation i'm not good at but i should
come back to the question your question
was when did i discover i was good at
math or that i loved math and it was a
very discreet moment i was in a class
well actually i was in a geometry class
and i was doing badly
uh so i had taken the first freshman you
know in high school algebra 2 course
i i was a little ahead i had done some
algebra already in middle school so i
was in this algebra 2 course it was fine
they put me in a geometry class taught
by the football coach which is a strange
thing a lot of times the coach is
thought to be someone suitable to teach
math i don't know why that like it's a
very manly subject or some ridiculous
thing and health too right health too
okay so anyway mr white the football
coach was teaching geometry and i was
really bored in the class
and not doing well that's always been
true my whole academic career when i'm
bored i don't pay attention and don't do
well
so i was bored and getting maybe a c or
something and then something great
happened which was that the school
said you shouldn't be doing this badly
rather than punishing me or putting me
in some remedial geometry they said we
think you should skip geometry and do
pre-calculus starting tomorrow
and that was great because then suddenly
i had something interesting to learn
about and my teacher mr johnson had a
beard he had gone to mit
he he wasn't the football coach
he he seemed like oh
i thought okay i could learn from mr
johnson and he was very difficult
um but fair but he asked us a lot of
hard questions and so in the course of
one of his
uh discussions one day he mentioned that
there was a certain geometry problem of
all things he wasn't teaching geometry
teaching pre-calculus he said here's
this hard geometry problem and i've been
suggesting it to students for years and
i've never seen anyone do it
he just mentioned that
i thought that's interesting
let's you know i'll tell you the problem
if you're curious it was if two angle
bisectors of a triangle are congruent
okay so remember an angle bisector cuts
the angle in half equally right so if
two angle bisectors have the same length
the triangle is isosceles sort of seems
like it would be true and in fact the
other direction is easy if the triangle
is isosceles showing that the angle
bisectors are congruent is pretty easy
but to do it this direction if congruent
angle bisectors then the triangle is
isosceles
mr johnson said that's a hard problem so
i thought that's very interesting then
he said actually i don't know how to do
it
and i thought you're kidding mr johnson
doesn't with the beard can't do
the angle bisector problem how could
that be
so i thought okay i you know until that
time in my life i could do any geometry
problem the school asked me to do so i
started working on it and i couldn't do
it
and you know i spent a day or two on it
i still couldn't do it i thought about
it all day long then it was weeks i
still couldn't do it then it was months
and the whole time i was in french class
and they would say you know conjugate
these verbs and they used to have like
this kid had to conjugate this verb and
then it would go to the next kid and it
would go around the room like a train
and i could feel it was coming toward me
but i was thinking about the angle
bisectors
so it was really messing me up but both
in basketball and in french class
and um i got obsessed with this question
okay so you're wondering what happened
well
at some point i thought i had solved it
and it was a prep school and mr johnson
lived close by
uh to the campus and so i asked could i
i think i got it can i come over to your
house and show it to you
it was a sunday morning and he was there
in his pajamas his little kids were
there and he sat at his kitchen table i
showed him each step he carefully
sternly checked each step he said it's
correct proof
and then he wrote a little note to the
headmaster of the school stephen has
real talent
gets me choked up thinking about it
so just moving
from that point when you used you found
you started to love math and you
at some point uh
did grad school became a mathematician
studied
became an applied mathematician and
studied non-linear dynamics complex
networks um you're and then
uh sort of the
um synchronization emergence of of
certain kinds of behaviors
um
that
you know where order appears out of sort
of seemingly chaotic right um
behaviors
and then you wrote your first popular
book in 2003
a book called sync related to your work
first of all what was the inspiration
for that and what were the challenges of
going from teaching in a classroom to
writing a book you know my whole life i
always thought i wanted to be a teacher
or if not a teacher a science writer so
we skipped over that i always thought i
would like to be a science writer and i
applied for summer internships and kept
getting rejected
and including famously to me i mean i
saved the letter from the new york times
even our copy boys have journalism
degrees interesting and i didn't know
exactly what that meant but i knew it
was insulting
so
so um
okay so i couldn't be a science writer
but i always kind of wanted to be so
anyway yes um in the course of trying to
solve the kinds of problems you need to
solve to be a professor and get tenure
and do the whole academic track
and um
there wasn't any place for writing for
the public that was not considered
a good strategy or advisable it shows
misplaced priorities right so
discouraged right totally discouraged
yeah i mean my department chairman said
even when i wanted to write a textbook
the book that you mentioned it that you
had read
um the chair said it won't help it won't
really hurt you but it takes away time
from your research and it definitely
won't help you
so you shouldn't do it
but i did anyway because i really wanted
to and i i was frustrated that there
weren't any books in my subject in
nonlinear dynamics and chaos that i felt
were readable for a beginner
so i just felt this compulsion glad he
did it i'm glad you disregarded that
advice
uh i think it was turned out to be a
good choice i mean a lot of people have
thanked me for that book over the years
and also set you down a path right to
yeah i did what i wanted to do i also
didn't get tenure at mit
so i mean they they played their cards
they they were open about what mattered
to them and what mattered to me wasn't
exactly what but on the other hand
cornell said well move here and we'll
give you tenure two years early so i
thought that sounded better
[Laughter]
but but to the question of sync
um
the book sync i
well a bit of a
i had just gotten married to carol who's
here uh in the audience
[Laughter]
ready to crawl under her seat and we um
were having our
first child at that point and there was
a popular tv show called who wants to be
a millionaire
and we were starting to think about how
would we ever pay for college on a
professor's salary
um this is honestly what was in our head
i'm sorry maybe you don't regret asking
this question
but i was thinking i would like to find
a way to make some money and some i was
aware of people getting big advances for
writing books for the public about
science
and
carol said to me if you always say you
want to do this if you are serious and
you want to do it i think this would be
a good time to do it
because um
who wants to be a millionaire i kept
trying to get on they wouldn't call me
back
so
so anyway i did put in a proposal to
write this book for the public
um used an agent you know that other
science people my friend brian green had
used the same agent and he said use
these people they'll get you a big
advance
and that all turned out to be true and
it was good and our kids are now in
college
now i did have the story that i wanted
to tell yeah i i did but
that was true my whole life the question
why then was for the money you have the
contract you have to deliver a
manuscript now yeah yeah there are
certain challenges to producing an
entire book that people want to read
right
yeah what was like maybe the the top
challenge and how did you overcome it
the top challenge is self-censorship
um i
i
start typing and immediately want to hit
the backspace or the delete button i you
know as you mentioned mathematicians are
trained to be critical they only want to
say what's exactly true and it always
requires a million caveats so as a
writer i was very troubled by
the difficulty of writing a true
sentence
and um so i was painfully slow writer
and i had friends advise me the first
draft has to be terrible don't worry
about that don't you can edit later just
spit it out but i had trouble doing that
and it was a painful book to write it
was a slow process but what has helped
me since then because you mentioned to
me before we started the conversation
you were hoping maybe i could share some
tips i do have a tip which is if you're
a self-censoring person and a lot of us
are
um the dictation function on your phone
is very hard
so i i turn on my nowadays when i write
a book i turn on my phone and talk into
the phone and dictate in the notes app
and
don't expect it to be any good and just
talk while i'm walking the dog so i'll
think of what section do i want to write
and then just start talking
and it gives the book a very
conversational sound with automatic
rhythms that are like spoken english
because that's how it was generated
and most of it is bad but it's easy
enough to delete it later
but sometimes there are good nuggets
right but it gets rid of the problem of
trying to constantly self-edit yeah i'm
also i never learned to touch type so my
typing is very bad which makes it easier
to delete
so
so i think the dictation gets me to
generate thousands of words in a day
which is otherwise impossible for me and
then editing i love to do afterward
let's just skip forward one uh again
quickly to
your most recent book um infinite powers
which came out in 2019 2019
i think of it as your magnum opus and
it's about
calculus what it is the history of it
and just
to me like reading that book
anyone can read that book
and come away with
a very very
good
sense of what calculus is and how it
works without actually having to do any
calculations right and so talk talk
through a little bit of your evolution
as a writer from sync now to oh thank
you infinite powers and that's a very
astute question i really wanted to tell
the story it was a love story of
calculus and i love the subject of
calculus it's my favorite part of math
i think it's one of the all-time
greatest ideas right up there with
democracy and quantum mechanics
you know and darwinism and you know
they're just a few relativity there are
a few ideas that really change the world
and calculus absolutely is one of them
but you wouldn't get that from a
calculus book you would get a thousand
pages of integration by parts and
related ratings
so
it seems terrible there's something so
monumental here and this needs to be
told a large part of the population
doesn't know anything about it our
population either doesn't know it or has
a distorted picture of it from the
course that they took right okay so i
wanted to convey that but how
is it just about the ideas of calculus
is it about the people stories of
calculus or is it about how calculus
changed the world
and i want it to be about all three
so i want it to be both the applications
but not both i want three i want the
applications i want the history and i
want the ideas
and i didn't really know how to do that
but i knew that that's what i wanted to
do
and so rather than write an outline of
something that i couldn't imagine
i just walked around talking into my
phone
for a long time it was extremely
painful to write that book i keep using
the word pain don't i
writing is hard writing all right let's
let's just get that you know yeah
i wrote a first draft that i was
moderately happy with and my great
editor ayman dolan said it's it's really
nice but wouldn't it be great this is
editor speak you know wouldn't it be
nice if every chapter had something like
that chapter where you explain how
calculus helped make hiv
into a manageable chronic illness rather
than a near-certain death sentence which
was the way it was when aids was
ravaging the country
so he said that was a compelling example
wouldn't it be nice if every chapter had
that and i thought yes it sure would be
nice
that's what i meant to do the first but
i hadn't written that book yet so then i
had to rewrite the whole book and then
after i did that he said the book is so
much better now it's really great
wouldn't it be nice if there was a whole
story that went all the way through from
beginning to end like one principle or
one big idea that would
so i said you're right that would be
good
and then i had to write that book
so it was unbelievably hard for the
family i i keep the pain wasn't just me
like psychic pain of my own work it was
very hard for the family i was upstairs
in my attic working my dog missed me my
wife missed me
kids i mean it was really not easy no
but i'm very proud of the result it
feels to me like and actually the ending
of the book came to me on one of those
walks and as i was dictating i started
crying it was such a perfect ending
really a weird out-of-body experience
those of you who are creative musicians
or artists or whatever you know
sometimes your art takes you you didn't
see it coming and this is what an
outline will not do for you
a real writer like real but you know
some
let yourself go i didn't know how to do
that when i wrote sync
and i and i was very happy with um these
weird deep wells of subconscious stuff
that the words came out like paul
mccartney has talked about that with
writing i'm not saying i could write
lyrics like paul mccartney but you know
what i mean you're a writer yourself so
sometimes
your own art can really
um transport you so the last few minutes
i i want to talk also of course about
our podcast yes thank you spent the last
few years producing uh first the drivex
and now the newest um podcast uh that
you are uh hosting for quanta is called
the joy of why
and i wonder if you could maybe just
start from talking a little bit about
what was uh the joy of x about and
what did we change for the joy of y well
yeah so
the joy of x was our
first of all thanks a lot for letting me
be part of the quanta team i love your
whole
enterprise your magazine your stories
you are yourself fantastic as no no no
no okay we don't have to go well
let me let me say this
since we're going back and and uh
complement each other
okay in thinking about a new podcast for
quanta i remember being on vacation with
my family
and thinking you know what should this
new podcast be about who should be the
host and it just sort of
dawned on me
the host has to be steve strogatz it
really it occurred to me i reached out i
was so thrilled that you said yes
because i was thinking i would love to
figure out a way to do a podcast tonight
to me the timing was perfect as the
rolls-royce of science journalism i just
was delighted to do it okay well
um joy of x to me was based on the
vision that
the radio is intimate
that podcasts are coming into your ear
and that's the most intimate thing to
listen to someone else's stories and
words so i felt i wanted to have
scientists and mathematicians talk about
their inner lives what does it feel like
to make discoveries why are they in love
with the questions they work on what
were their own journeys so it's a very
intimate show about
the scientists
themselves
it tended to be meandering i i
deliberately wanted a very spontaneous
conversational vibe with them and we
didn't have
much planned out we let it go where it
went
the joy of why
is
uh about the questions
it puts the big questions first so are
you more interested in black holes or
the scientists who work on black holes
both are reasonable answers if you're
more interested in black holes and then
you will learn a lot about
you know the origin of life black holes
why do we have to sleep it's all about
the great timeless mysteries of science
and i mean it's not like we're
neglecting the scientists we are talking
to living breathing scientists and they
do tell their stories and there are very
um spontaneous and animated moments in
our conversations but we're really
sticking to the conversation about the
big questions and
current thinking about them part of this
conversation has been about transitions
right your transition from
a mathematician teacher to a writer and
now to a podcast host like what did you
have to learn so the teacher side of me
sometimes hears my guess
saying things in a way that i'm
imagining my listeners may not exactly
get it and so i might rephrase
uh
what the person has just said and a lot
of times i'm truly confused by what they
just said i'm not playing possum it's
not a gimmick like are you saying such
and such i really don't know are you
saying something
so i will ask those what i hope are
clarifying questions
and um sometimes those really land i
think
absolutely absolutely i think you know
again it just shows what a great teacher
you are
i think we're really lucky to have you
as the host for the joy of why i hope
all of you will
listen to it uh we have a trailer out
right now next thursday is the first
full episode uh you can subscribe all
your all the major podcasting platforms
so thank you all for coming tonight
you